the number of people in England waiting  to start routine hospital treatment has  reached a record high seven million  patients in England were waiting to  start treatment at the end of August the  equivalent of one in eight people now  that figure has increased for 28 months  in a row far above the five percent  Target more than 43 percent of people  had to wait more than four hours at  accident in emergency the worst  performance ever some had to wait even  longer thirty two thousand seven hundred  people had to wait 12 hours or more to  be admitted to hospital after speaking  to an a e doctor that's more than the  total for the whole of the last decade